又大漲了
今天大漲500多點
轉眼間46000了
前一陣子才39000
哲哲 你們每個人幫我算財產
對啦 我一下子賺到快1500萬
So what
重點是你能不能賺錢
我今天最開心的是
我的矽晶圓 環球晶漲停
這也不是重點
我今天跟你講三個重點
第一個 台股重返46000
5萬將提前達標嗎
投資朋友一定很多人想知道
5萬會不會達標
每個人都想知道的事情對不對
會不會8月就5萬點
第二個 我的0050
1億的0050
11天而已
11天左右賺了快1500萬
1億賺1500萬
哲哲你躺著賺
我希望你能了解到
我坐這邊 我待在這邊
就是為大家服務
這些錢我並沒有在乎
到時候我要再捐一台救護車
第三台救護車
這個公開場合已經都捐了好幾千萬
第三個 何時出這比較重要
第三個 MSCI新增很多記憶體的股票
有一個就是我們的群聯
還有一個是我之前的 不見的戀人
已經把他先分一陣子
南亞科 三進三出
會不會四進四出 會不會五進五出
這些飆股今天通通一次講個夠
台股天天大漲
距離台股大跌到今天才2週多的時間
就從最低39384點
一路噴到突破46000
11天的時間
台股就漲了快7000點
真的太強啦
而投資長的飆股
今天又是狂噴猛噴
國巨今天噴漲停啦
只有投資長在跌停板456.5元
當天告訴大家
這邊就是要買
這幾天一路噴出
由低到高已經大漲超過45%
還有投資長一直說太委屈的環球晶
也連2天漲停啦
中美晶也差點就漲停
另外今天早上MSCI
新增了南亞科 群聯和華邦電
想知道投資長是怎麼看的嗎
投資長的會員們
都已經要財富翻倍了
你手上還沒有飆股嗎
接下來就交給我們經濟日報選股冠軍
單季188%的紀錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲榮投資長 投資長好
Lily 各位投資朋友大家好
又漲500點
如果11天前
有個分析師跟你講砸1億
那你要砸多少錢
你們那53% 還有投票表決的
我們來投票的
有53%我知道你還有錢
現在有沒有覺得
投這票覺得有點丟臉
怎麼會還有錢
叫你把豬公 豬仔 通通宰來拿來用
你就有錢嘛
我不知道你現在是開心大於難過
還是難過大於開心
很矛盾的感覺對不對
股票漲上去了
今天也有人問我
我的國巨1200怎麼解套
奇怪 國巨1200你怎麼解套
你買1張500塊的國巨
那你現在就1700嘛 是不是
你800多元就可以解套啦 是
你逢低又不買
哲哲我沒錢了
不要騙自己 你有錢
不要騙自己 我知道你還有錢
不要截這一段
真的啦
39000你自己看
哪個分析師在39000
敢給你用力買
你告訴我這個39000耶
而且我是前一天就預告跌破39000
前一天預告跌破40000
40000來到39000我就買
買1億0050
所有的新聞
那一天至少8家報紙雜誌
不只 光是電視台就8家了
對不對 沒錯吧 對
因為Lily那時候在旁邊 是不是
8家採訪我
一家接著一家來
一家接著一家
我說對不起 我只給你10分鐘的時間
因為我太忙了
新聞媒體 報章雜誌可能幾十家
全部人都知道我買1億0050
隔天你還可以跟我買相同的位置
你不理我
幸福來的又急又快
11天的時間
2 4 6 8 10
10天而已喔
我給你1天的時間
後來10天彈了多少
快7000點
39000多到現在46000多
不是快7000點 是
投資朋友
我跟你講當我的粉絲就有個好處
因為你看我第一次
哲哲是誰 哲哲買1億喔
在炫耀 炫什麼耀
你要有本事
第一個 很多人講得好
第一個 你要能湊出這1億
第二個你要敢買這個1億 公開買
第三個 你要買了1億以後
馬上1天的時間
就馬上賺了1000多萬
那我再跟你講更誇張的事
你們全部人都可以作證
沒有我下台一鞠躬
更誇張的是 你們自己看
我請問大家一件事情
哪一個分析師是在連續3年
都在低檔的時候有沒有
之前跌6000點有沒有看到
沒錯吧 沒錯
我在那時候
去年這時候才17000
你看股市漲多凶
去年4月的時候關稅議題
我說川普馬上怎麼樣
馬上就會取消這個關稅
而且會透過他的Truth social
他的一個社群媒體
他自己的獨特社群媒體
會透過他的社群媒體
果然凌晨好像11 12點的時候
他說關稅要延後
馬上股市噴出去
而且我還預告說
就算股市大漲1000點
就算股市漲停也要追
有沒有印象
有嘛 對不對
有 有印象 來
投資朋友如果我有刻意說謊話
有非常誇大
我下台一鞠躬
大家都可以作證
我就在這附近
18418點這附近進場台灣50
連續2年
後來漲了3萬點
連續3年的時候
2024年更漂亮
等一根又長又黑又粗的長黑K棒
在這邊我盡量能空手就空手
跌了4000多點
在這邊馬上反彈
所以這邊很多人說
哲哲會不會打第二隻腳
我說你們要幹嘛
奇怪 每天在想那些萬一幹什麼
哪個分析師可以連續3年
在股災的時候
都選一個相對最低點
3年都是相對最低點
你看2024年也是最低點這一天
今年也是一樣
一次叫運氣好
兩次叫碰巧
三次叫做神蹟 知道嗎 奇蹟啊
我的奇蹟一再出現
所有網友你們自己見證
說有沒有講 有好不好
今天國巨又漲停 直接賺爛了
國巨就說嘛
你看我那時候說
不要說我說
我說我做人很公道
不要說什麼瑤池金母我欺負他啦
我說沒有啦
他們也很辛苦
基金經理人壓力很大
我們都感受到
因為很多人覺得
哲哲在嘻笑怒罵
他們不知道其實我壓力很大
只是我去享受這個壓力
我告訴我自己
我是真心為會員好
我真心為粉絲好
沒什麼好壓不壓力的
我就度過這一切
你懂不懂我的意思
所以我就做自己而已
可是我做自己之前
我希望是把我的大愛給大家
帶給大家 知道嗎
來 愛哲哲有沒有
有 你看大家都說有
中美晶今天還是有漲
不用擔心 環球晶會拉起來
00981A都30了
而且我是不是說過
我說如果是我
如果今天是哲哲我
我可能要買ETF
我會先買00981A
我是不是這樣講 是
然後我再換台灣50
因為反彈00981A會彈比較快
00981A彈了快30%
我如果1億
我如果不當分析師
我是少賺1500萬
你不要看我現在賺1500萬
我是可以賺3000萬的
只是我說如果我不當分析師
我也不買00981A
我就直接買國巨就好啦
是不是我有講這句話
買環球晶就好了 有沒有講 有
這樣賺更多
所以你不要羨慕我賺1500萬
我是因為你們 不然我少賺
我也可以買正2
只是我是公眾人物
公眾人物當然我就什麼
我其他的生活不管
因為我不知道哪一天
會不會不小心闖黃燈
可是重點是我投資的道德標準要很高
這個是我對自己的要求
投資朋友
所以我不會私底下去買股票
我不需要 我少賺一點就好
我要讓你知道什麼叫大愛
我當分析師
你看我賺1500萬
我其實少賺幾千萬
我每次都這樣跟你講
投資朋友 我不能做期貨喔
賺更多 每次都低檔進場
誰敢這樣子
拋頭露臉還1億
那是你們看我覺得嘻笑怒罵
1天就漲上去了
你告訴我誰能那麼厲害
我早就跟大家講
我的天份在這邊知道嗎
年底哲哲即將成為傳說
沒有錯 5萬點
可是我跟你講
你們都是一群渣男渣女
現在點閱率回不到
直播人數回不到1 2萬啦
你知道嗎 之前點閱率2 30萬
現在沒辦法
No no no
你們真的讓我很傷心你知道嗎
哪一天大跌
我就把我的頻道封起來 OK嗎
就給那些死忠粉絲
我是認真講
給會員看
或者給粉絲看
直播要按讚多一點你知道
你看 4000多
只有189給我按讚
我快氣死了
嘴巴說愛我 真的愛我嗎 來
今天就有人說 哲哲
我真的
為什麼這麼多愛哲哲 你知道嗎
還有人問哲哲是誰
為什麼這麼多人愛他
有沒有看到 是不是
我的回答很簡單 有沒有看到
不好意思 來
引用人家的
引用這個美女的 來
應該是美女
是美女 我這樣講沒禮貌 對不起
哲哲是誰 為什麼這麼多人愛他
因為很多人在認識我之前
不知道什麼是愛
哲哲是誰 為什麼這麼多人愛他
因為很多人在認識我之前
不知道什麼是愛
認識我以後才知道什麼是愛
什麼是大愛
什麼是股票的愛
什麼是希望你過得比我好的愛
我那時候有沒有說
再給自己一次愛哲哲的機會
不然你會後悔一輩子有沒有講 有
我捨身取義
捨己救人
1億丟下去
壓力多大
那是現在對了耶
倖存者偏差耶
哲哲好厲害
如果不對呢 怎麼辦
可是神奇的是我連續對3年
都在最低點附近
還有2年就是剛好最低點那一天
另外是隔天 隔一兩天
都很強
來 我有沒有講
這句話都越來越準
你再看一下我的這個東西
我看今天很多梗
應該大家都會截圖
當你覺得39000的台股
是可割可棄的時候
沒有錯吧 是
39000沒錯吧 你自己看
在這邊啊 你是可割可棄的時候
我在買進啊
當你覺得39000的台股
是可割可棄
可以割除 可以丟棄的時候
不好意思
我看你是43000的時候
我覺得你很可惜
現在46000了
我覺得可憐
等到46000 47000
現在是可憐了
5萬的時候是可悲
可惜 可憐 可悲
不好意思
你們現在已經感覺到很可憐了
有些人 現在空手的人最可憐
空手的人最可憐
我都說過
我昨天不是說
不用再測試一次吧
我昨天不是說AI
我就他要當中國信託客服
就是中國信託客服
它也可以當
富邦金控的客服啊
那我富邦金控的客服
我是不是說過很簡單
我說過那這個AI就很重要了
為什麼
你看這個訂單
本來100萬是4個月前對不對
我再給你推廣
我再講一次喔
託管推論這一塊
會爆炸
我再給你第二個預告喔
華爾街的沒有給你預告
我很屌直接跟你講喔
我認為託管推論這一塊的爆發程度
會比AI agent
就是你們說的龍蝦
我再給你預告喔
沒有分析師跟你講這句話喔
華爾街也沒有喔
託管推論這一塊
會比龍蝦 就是AI agent
就是你是AI
你幫我代理我的E-mail
我的信箱
這是AI代理程式 是
發展更恐怖
Anthropic不就靠這個
我跟你講接下來要賺這個
託管推論
Managed Inference
這個很簡單
就是我請
譬如說我請那個
這家公司
CoreWeave
這家公司有沒有
輝達的兒子
我請他怎麼樣
譬如說我這樣講
AI 我知道現在一般的AI
已經能跟我對話啦 對
所以我請他幫我推論出來
幫我生一個一般的AI程式
專門For我們富邦金控
或我們中國金控
我們是摩爾 不好意思
專門For富邦金控
或是中國信託
這一個 然後最好還能串接
我在講話的同時
我可以查出你的額度來
甚至線上可以幫你直接申請成功的
這有可能的
越少人力越好 我賺越多
越少人力 我光是客服人員
一年台灣就要省500億
你有沒有想過
你想想看做託管推論這家公司
現在不多耶
等到你知道的時候
已經如雨後春筍般了
昨天有人說謝謝哲哲
讓我知道這個生意頭腦
對啊 他說可以做啊
我說以後啊
你餐飲業也可以啊
不需要接電話啦 你懂不懂
客服 你可以找一個客服
幫你接電話 你懂不懂
接完電話就直接串接 怎麼樣
或直接幫你訂單處理了 你懂不懂
以後不只是Ubereats訂啊
你也可以用電話訂啊 你懂不懂
幫你做客服啊
串接你的啊
串接你的Line程式
或串接什麼程式啊
那我這些電信業者
或者是說電信業者的客服
中華電信客服也是每次都打不進去啊
你也可以串聯進去啊
我請CoreWeave
做託管推論
什麼意思
我告訴他我的需求
你生出一個AI程式
AI語音程式或AI程式
那我們公司的作業流程
那我們公司的客服
航空業也是一樣 航運業一樣
我們都常常要打電話
這些抱怨的電話
我可以用AI處理
我不要用人處理
客製化
什麼叫客製化
代表每一家公司都有這個需求
所以這個市場多大
你們看不出來而已啊
數字 記憶體多少
我算一下這個多少
一般的分析師是這樣子
華爾街分析師一般也是這樣子
台灣分析師也不怪他們
真的啦
不好意思 我講話比較屌
你們不知道這個市場
我再講一次
每一家公司都需要AI
你告訴我這個AI的市場多大
如果有人給我推這個 賣我程式
說不好意思喔
我們可以省兩個人力
那你多兩個人力
一個人力我們平均薪水現在都
今年薪水不錯
大概80到100萬
兩個人力你省200萬
200萬喔
而且200萬是永久的喔
我們可以做別的事情
不一定要Fire人家
200萬
他說你一年我只賣你100萬
買不買 買啊
那100萬他可能投啊
這個人賣100萬
那個賣100萬
那他投資個幾千萬去買這個
去跟人家買這個託管推論
O不OK
生出那個程式O不OK
再講一次
託管推論這一塊
以後會變成主流
比AI agent還快
還更是主流
今年靠漲的
從26000漲到40000是
AI agent
可是AI agent你知道什麼問題嗎
AI agent是你幫我做事
他沒有一個商業體系 為什麼
你幫我做事情
對啦 你幫我比價
然後呢
你會因為你幫我比價
去買這程式嗎
No no no 不一定喔
你聽得懂嗎
可有可無嘛
Agoda最便宜的價格
Trip.com最便宜的機票又怎麼樣
最有購買力道的是誰
公司啊 公司行號
你告訴他 不好意思
我幫你省了500億的人力
你現在只要
我現在只要跟你收一年10億
你要不要 OK啊
就這麼簡單 OK啊
那這個
他要跟銀行收這個錢
或者是他要跟一般餐飲業
或一般各個公司
跟你收這個錢
他一定要先透過
我不可能
找那麼多程式來寫嘛
或設計師或買GPU
或買AI伺服器嘛
你有AI伺服器
你幫我跑程式
我有什麼需求 你幫我跑
跑出來這個程式
這個語音客服或這個程式
利用託管推論這一塊
GPU晶片你都提供
程式你幫我想 幫我生
懂不懂 答案出來了
這個需求多大
沒有分析師跟你講這一塊 No
他們在記憶體怎麼樣
光是這一塊你就知道
我再講一次
每一家公司都需要AI
以後都這樣
因為他可以改進他很多程式
所以這個跟2000年差太多了
講那些的人
根本就不知道什麼是AI
記住一句話 3年前
ChatGPT一出來的時候
全台灣只有我郭哲榮曾經講
這是接下來改變人類的命運
只有我講AI股市會漲一整年
有印象的舉手
後來我就說改成3年
到現在第3年
我再跟你講 現在開始
不只 還會再好3年
你們趕快把錢湊齊
真的還會再好3年
所以這些記憶體
被動元件漲停的漲停很正常
那交給最一般的分析師解釋
我們那個EPS多少
我們這個毛利率多少
這叫看數字說話
我是預言家 不一樣
我不一樣 你久了就知道
看哲哲一次少一次
我跟你講
越是了解股市的險惡
越是了解股市的人
越知道我跟別人不一樣
只有那種不懂股市的人
覺得哲哲你講得很正常
我是跟你說真的
被動元件我是專家
2018年我受傷過
我有賺大錢也有受傷過
所以你看這一次
我吃他豆腐幾次 三進三出
今年是兩進兩出
第二進還沒出
你懂我的意思嗎 還沒出
你可不可以買華新科
禾伸堂 信昌電
他們都是聯動的
所以有人國巨嫌太貴買華新科
現在謝謝我 愛上我了
愛上我的滋味是不是很棒
是不是
全台灣是只有哲哲
敢提前喊破4萬要買1億
我喜歡提前喊 沒錯
好不好 OK嗎 來
ETF經理人都在看哲哲分析股市
蠻多人看我的節目的
國巨太扯了 好不好
以後你就是我的準哲
能分析高力嗎
高力不是我的股票 好不好
今天怎麼感覺一群人洗版 來
相信哲哲 國巨 環球晶賺飽
謝謝大家
不要一直洗版
同一個畫面不要一直洗版
重複一個畫面
超過三次就要先封鎖你了
我只進不去了
愛哲哲是至死不渝的愛
千萬別這樣說 我最怕這種
有些人愛情都說一輩子愛的時候
那都不一定很長 好不好
你們先愛我今年就好
先今年就好
我嘴巴這樣講是先今年 OK嗎
幫大家科普花時間研究
我不只科普花時間研究
我直接預告未來
那些科普是網路上的資訊
不會告訴你說
沒有一個新聞
沒有一個現在報導告訴你
我說託管推論這一塊
就是你幫我們公司
整個作業流程
然後改進
或是以後會是趨勢
你今天不是台灣大哥大買精誠資訊嗎
溢價好像30幾%吧
為什麼 一堆工程師在那邊啊
你懂我的意思嗎
雖然現在寫程式很簡單
但是工程師比較了解這些程式的架構
以後也是這樣
深入各個公司 OK嗎
這個跟大家講好不好
夜盤46000沒站穩
你們每天在緊張東緊張西
是不是
為什麼南亞科科噴 華邦電平盤
因為南亞科的中實戶 主力比較有錢
業界滿有名的
今天6000人看直播
鴻海為什麼跌
鴻海就是昨天沒有劉揚偉出來
氣死 我本來以為劉揚偉出來
昨天是代理的CEO
講得不溫不火 好不好
我覺得就是很普通
他有講說很好
但是那個很好沒有比大家好
聽得懂我在說什麼嗎
再給你強調一次 託管推論
你以後看到
我是全世界第一個直接跟你講的
沒有人敢講
會比AI agent市場更大
因為每一家公司
或者是說我要兜售給這些公司
我要兜售給金控公司
我兜售給一般的業者 零售業者
然後我怎麼生出來一個語音客服
或者是我怎麼改進你的作業流程
這個以後很恐怖
你懂不懂
以前會覺得改進作業流程很難 很麻煩
現在其實都可以做得到
都可以做得到 你聽得懂嗎
好 來 我們來看一下
所以我們今天推出逆轉188專案
好不好
最近剛好股票比較強
所以推個專案
要不要參加隨便你
逆轉188
剛好哲哲是獲利188%的男人
好不好
全台灣都知道
經濟日報有史以來
最高的選股紀錄保持者就是我
所以我打破很多紀錄
怎麼會有人覺得哲哲是運氣好呢
運氣好 你敢買1億喔
你敢公開給人家笑喔
我買1億就準備不要給人家笑的啦
你懂不懂
準備我笑那些空手的
我希望你不是真的空手的
我希望你就算還有錢
只是一點點有錢
我不希望藉由污辱你來成就我
我不需要
我希望是你跟我一起提升
好不好 我是認真跟你講
我跟你講可憐 可惜 可悲
那只是節目的語言煽動力而已
讓你記得而已
可是我沒有 我不需要批評你
我不需要踐踏其他人
來增加我自己的自信 不需要
我希望是你跟我一起賺錢
可是我要告訴你一件事
為什麼我買最保守的台灣50
我隨便買個00981A
我如果不當分析師
買個00981A 買個正2
然後甚至於買期貨
或者買被動元件
隨便都賺個 多賺個2 3000萬
為什麼我沒這樣做
因為我是分析師
因為我寧願當分析師
把愛給大家
我少賺一點沒關係
但只要你們有愛 有愛我
真的覺得哲哲是為你們好
那就夠了
你知道嗎 哲哲之前順風順水
然後有些同業
有些人在網路上
一定要講我以前的東西
哪個分析師沒有賠過錢
哪個分析師沒有賺過錢
可是我只要賺的時候
比賠的時候多很多就好
人在做天在看 我沒差
大不了我自己操作我也沒差
可是我告訴大家
我自始至終我就覺得
我希望你們比我好
我自始至終是這樣認為
好不好 逆轉188專案
你自己參考 好不好
來 股票要漲停了
來看一下國巨漲停對不對 對
是不是 我昨天有沒有說過
既生瑜何生亮
既生周子瑜
不是 周瑜啦
周子瑜
最近好像聽到什麼TWICE
什麼周子瑜要離開了 我不知道
不知道為什麼跳出這個東西來
Threads
既生周瑜 何生諸葛亮
既生瑜何生亮
既生巨禾伸堂
我有沒有說禾伸堂怎麼樣
你看今天禾伸堂就沒起來了
我說禾伸堂昨天都快700元了
國巨怎麼可以
有沒有看到
怎麼可以差那麼多
你看他們今天兩個就拉近了
有沒有看到 是
國巨今天就漲停板
禾伸堂就下去了
還是有漲
所以既生巨禾伸堂
兩個就是這樣伯仲之間
有沒有講 都講了
都講在前面
這個邏輯很簡單
一個族群如果是一起發動
通常這是真的
如果一個族群就一兩檔股票發動
那個不一定會動
一個族群一起發動代表是
就是他們這個
這個被動元件 這個行業
因為有些人可能 某一家中實戶
大戶是跟這家公司派合作
你聽得懂嗎 有可能 是
那另外一個大戶
B大戶又是跟
可能跟第二家
被動元件的公司合作
或者他知道這個消息
所以他們會一起動
因為他們都知道未來的發展很好
這是有可能的
哪個分析師跟你講這個東西
不會跟你講那麼仔細
技術分析 如果這個重慶南路
現在沒什麼書局了
一般書局 誠品書局買到的書
技術分析就能讓你賺百萬 賺1億
你相信喔 那賠光光剛剛好
一定要技術分析加籌碼面 加心理面
你告訴我
哪一個技術分析告訴你
4萬點這邊是買進
破線 破季線
我再講一件事
現在大家純技術分析或怎麼樣
或者覺得AI是泡沫
根本就不知道我講那一段
如果你剛才聽得懂我這一段
你還覺得AI是泡沫
我只能說你傻得可以
我再講一次
如果我剛才今天講AI客服語音
光是客服語音
我講的是其中AI某一個東西而已
他AI已經聰明到
智力已經比我們所有人都強了
這是事實 你知道嗎
我們要 比如說我們有一些公司跟公司
要改合約
他可以講出來你邏輯上的問題
一堆問題
很恐怖
一般的律師
這就像下象棋一樣 你知道嗎
下象棋或是下圍棋
他已經贏不了人類
人類已經贏不了他
因為人類沒辦法像電腦想得那麼
思考這麼縝密
所以你在
因為法律是這樣子
邏輯上要很強
他的邏輯上思考程度
已經比一般人縝密十倍以上了 沒錯
所以你就要去改法條 改條款
你交給他真的很恐怖
我可以利用他做很多東西
法律客服也可以
太多東西了 你懂我的意思嗎
真的 這個我跟大家講好不好
人型機械人也有機會 好不好
力積電有機會嗎
我們稍微看一下
雖然你這樣問法有點討厭
力積電線型不錯 好不好
只是黃董走了
相信黃董年底就懂
黃董走了是覺得蠻可惜 你知道嗎
可是我就覺得人生就是這樣子
燃燒最後一刻
那時候還法說會
我也希望哲哲燃燒到最後一刻
只是我到越老
我可能錄影時間越少 好不好
這個跟大家講
因為我覺得集中火力
你不覺得我現在錄影時間越來越少
還是錄得比一般老師多一些
可是我的績效越來越準
你有沒有覺得 有喔
是不是 真的啦
不用真不真的
你問大家就好
所以我覺得力積電
我現在沒那麼喜歡
失去了一個
一個支柱嗎
一個支柱 真的好不好
這個跟大家講 也是奇葩啦
是不是
公司 雖然張忠謀幫他很多忙
但是你從那個力晶到力積電
浴火重生
他也是個負責任的人
他大可拍拍屁股走人 是不是
把債務
股份有限公司
把債務丟給銀行
他也不這樣做
光是這一點我就覺得
我覺得男人就是這樣子
重承諾 重責任
就是應該這樣做
所以我欣賞他 好不好
我欣賞他 只是可惜
黃崇仁走了
這是為什麼我特別解釋一下這檔股票
我就是還算欣賞他好不好
英雄惜英雄
不要這樣講自己
哲哲惜英雄
這樣好不好 這個跟大家講
所以力積電我沒有那麼看好的原因
不要說沒有那麼看好
就是說少了一個黃崇仁
我不知道這家公司是好還是壞
就是這樣子而已 好不好
我們可以選比較穩的嘛
就像我跟你講 什麼叫穩
前幾天
你記不記得前幾天每個人都在罵我
環球晶 環球晶
奇怪 環球晶2根漲停板
你就不理我
你知道嗎 那時候啊
我1億馬上賺1000萬
很多人說
哲哲你的環球晶好爛喔
哲哲你的環球晶跌到700多元耶
你真敢講
還有人故意 同業
都是同業在網路上留言
你700多元
你也敢講你賺1000萬喔
我說我很生氣啦
講這什麼話
我寧願我不賺那1000萬
你們根本不了解我
我再講一次
認識我的都知道
我寧願我不賺那1000萬
我寧願我台灣50賠錢
我也不要會員賠錢啦
我說真的啦
真的 我說真的好不好
就是我不會去刻意做這個事情
你知道嗎 是
是不是
投資朋友 我沒有開心耶
可是我說
人家講一句話沒有開心
可是我很開心 為什麼
778元是老天爺送給你的禮物耶
網路上一直在流傳啦
那時候我說
台積電600元是老天爺送的禮物
跌到500元 跌到400元
一堆人笑我
現在呢
我說你再也見不到600元台積電
你見得到嗎
見得到嗎 你告訴我
見不到
你現在是不是再也見不到
1000元的環球晶了
我不知道
環球晶還有得磨
但是2000元有機會
我自始至終跟你講 我告訴你
各行各業有關AI到時候都會缺貨
都會經過一輪缺貨
我再講一件事
這個託管推論
我們就是
我請你幫我寫個AI程式
符合我們公司的
以後會越來越多人在用
為什麼會越來越多人在用
我再講一次
以前 有人說
哲哲 下面剛才底下有人留言
硬要跟我聊這些
現在就有一些AI客服了
那個AI客服爛得要死好不好
跟我昨天講的差那麼多
我講的沒錯吧 沒錯
你以前遇到一些AI客服
好像白癡一樣
那個你講話會生氣
那是為了人力成本 省成本
可是現在AI客服是真的
你可以跟他對話起來
那你對話起來以後
他把你的需求記起來
比如說我要剪卡怎麼樣
自動要連接到我們的雲端系統 是
銀行的內部系統
然後幫你剪卡 幫你一次做完
以前是要人類幫你手動
現在不用
我知道你的需求
他都聽得懂我的互動
他不會再寫個程式
我知道你的互動以後
我知道你要剪卡以後
我自動電腦就幫你剪卡嗎
可是這個要一個程式產生
以前程式產生不了
因為以前AI像智障一樣
現在AI真的是AI
就是因為現在AI
像聰明的天才一樣
所以我們可以開始寫一些程式
寫這些程式
問題是我GPU
我要推論 我要導論
你知道嗎
我GPU去哪邊買 買不到
所以我找人幫我買
我找人幫我寫這些程式
而這些每一家公司都有需求
因為我只要省人力成本
我賺很多
每一家公司都可以省
所以以後貧富差距會越來越大
你們不會投資股票
會差距越來越大
很多人會覺得被剝削
是真的 我講實在話
可是你們很幸福
當你們選哲哲的時候
你們看得到未來
真的 這是我存在最大的意義
真的啦 你覺得黃崇仁到最後
為什麼最後一刻還開
開那個什麼法說會
他有差那個幾千萬嗎 沒有
真的 你們也不要看哲哲這樣子
我說真的 好不好
我覺得有時候得到
我運氣很好
老天至少沒給我太傻的腦袋
可是我覺得有時候
我也是取之於社會用之於社會
所以我該捐錢就捐錢
有時候我最開心就是捐錢
我也買很多好的車子
但是我還是會買
但是我覺得最充實的是買救護車
真的是這樣子 這個跟大家講
買個500萬救護車
不錯 很開心
雖然救護車越來越貴了
以前3 400
可是我很開心 我真的很開心
明年應該 照這個順序應該
有沒有可能年初就6萬
我會捐第三台救護車
這個進度很快
我有說過22台
22個縣市 好不好 OK
哲哲 智原繼續買
智原喔
智原要爆發的時間比較難抓
智原純粹是低檔而已好不好
說老實話
智原純粹是低檔
你聽得懂嗎 好不好
等他一下 好不好 OK嗎
那鴻海再不拉起來
我也打算要撤退
撤退是要成本附近
哲哲 鴻海怎麼看
就是我昨天講的
昨天代理CEO講話不夠霸氣
好不好 OK嗎
這個跟大家講
只能等劉揚偉什麼時候要講
比較好的話
哲哲寶貝群聯噴噴 謝謝你
剛才很多人說要跟我姓
要姓郭
OK 郭氏家族 大家好
群聯噴噴怎麼看後續
相信哲哲稱奇
所以我就是你的神奇寶貝
沒有 冷笑話
群聯噴噴噴怎麼看後續
群聯也是一樣
這個MSCI 你看我還是有做圖
MSCI概念股來看一下
來 新增6檔有沒有看到
三升喔 來
三升 三個市場升起來
好不好 三升三市
新增那個南亞科 華邦電
群聯有沒有看到 有
有沒有人顧有差
群聯就是便宜
群聯便宜啦 我有沒有講說
奇怪 你們都不理我
很多人 我都覺得那是同業
顧著念我 那念我的人很少
1445你不覺得是
老天爺送給你的禮物
你看現在反彈也差很多
2280除以1445 記一下
1445 也快60%了
Lily你有沒有想過 真的耶
真的差很多
快60%了 57% 是
57% 轉眼間
群聯你真的相信我也57%了
所以這一次的股災
根本就是老天爺送給你的禮物
從頭到尾都不會股災
我再講一次
你要了解我看到的未來
每一家公司以後都需要
有人幫你生成一個AI程式
幫你們簡化你們公司的人力 作業流程
或者是對外的客服語音
或怎麼樣 Whatever
這是無遠弗屆
以前為什麼沒有人做到
因為以前的AI程式
以前AI客服像死了一樣
現在是真的比大家聰明
這是事實
AI也比我聰明
我比較厲害的是
可是AI不會取代我
AI會取代那些死都不用AI的人
不論你智商多高
你不用AI就準備被淘汰
你記得我這句話
再強調我這句話
你不知道AI多恐怖
那你準備被淘汰
我跟你講AI很恐怖
你還去用了以後
你還覺得不怎麼樣
很危險
你記得我這句話
你認同我講的話
我有職業生涯危機了
我這個行業怎麼樣
汽車駕駛行業
那你還有得救
還能幫助你
第一個你要嘛就換工作
要嘛就是買AI股票
我是認真幫助你的
相信我 你們以後會謝謝我
真的 我覺得真的
與其說我賺錢
我覺得說幫助大家
讓大家有認知感 你知道嗎
有時候認知感
突然失業了好難過
可是我講了好幾年
我能接受這個事情
你就不會激動 是
你就不會難過了
你就覺得我反而有賺到錢了
你反而很開心 好不好
我是說真的希望幫助大家
一定要用AI
各行各業都要用AI
超乎你想像的智商
如果你不覺得
那你很危險 記得我這句話
哲哲 你硬要說
我會比人家成功就是
硬要說會比人家成功
我不去預設特別立場
我是看到證據在哪邊
我就辦到哪邊
證據在哪邊我就說到哪邊 OK嗎
南亞科 華邦電 群聯
南亞科的中實戶很猛
沒有關係 我們這一波也不錯是不是
我剛才說57%對不對
今天514
用530除以322好了 沒關係
他64% 所以我看喔
群聯看起來一開始
覺得群聯沒有漲很多對不對
其實現在快要追上南亞科的漲幅囉 是
一個57% 一個64%
有沒有看到
這個也不錯啊 是不是
哲哲怎麼看華邦電
華邦電好像沒有漲得比群聯多對不對
沒有怎麼看啦
華邦電如果殺下去我想買啦
因為我覺得我買一檔
因為說老實話
我只買一檔記憶體我覺得太少了
你懂不懂
就如同我有點後悔
我只買一檔國巨太少了
你懂不懂我的意思
我還是有點後悔
我那時候
當然其實我下去
我已經買很多股票了
有新會員趕快買環球晶啊
買中美晶啊
所以華邦電或者是說華亞科
不是華亞科 那個
2492 突然忘記了
華新科啦 這是焦家
那個焦師傅的
這個集團的
華新集團的股票
就是被動元件
一個是記憶體的
一個是那個被動元件的
這些我有想買 你知不知道
老二族群的股票
我也想買你知道嗎
我已經買很多老大了
但是買一個老二也不錯啊
因為大家還是
因為我一直有新會員你知道嗎
你看喔 我也沒有要跟大家推銷
這個188專案
可是就會很多人來問
今天還有人留言說
哲哲 我按那個要參加會員
怎麼沒人理我
不好意思 你現在按你要參加會員的
還真的有可能沒有人理你
等一下啦 好不好
太多人了
沒關係 你現在直接留言說你是哪一位
你再丟一下訊息給我好不好
按TG Line丟一下訊息給我好不好
這個跟大家講
不過誰沒有理你的再跟我講一下
真的不行打個入會專線啦
網路會比較快啦
真的沒有 入會專線應該會啦
我們會聽那個語音啦 好不好
會看一下誰偷懶
不是偷懶 我們公司的人很忙啦 好不好
那個京元電 聯電 廣達可以嗎
廣達都變阿達了
廣達要看今天的法說
助理看一下今天的法說好不好 OK
加碼聯電 人生尬電買個老二
全部都老二概念股
那個記憶體買老二 買華邦電
然後被動元件買華新科
然後那個先進製程不買台積電
買聯電 老二族群
不要啦 老二有時候差很多你知道嗎
我之前就買了聯電
少賺很多你知道嗎
又帥又有頭腦的哲哲
請問京元電 群創
這不是我的股票 沒關係
京元電我以前還被人家罵
現在都出掉了
京元電線型還好啦
看起來不太會噴
你看他這個陣子這麼多都沒有動
之前就沒有爆發的題材
漲上去以後頂多啦
這個看線型就知道
之前就在區間整理平台有沒有看到 對
看技術線型
大家可以學到
雖然這檔股票
不一定是你的股票 京元電
就算噴出去了
還是會在這個區間平台 懂嗎
懂不懂 了解
目前為止是老狗玩不出新把戲
目前 好不好
OK 講一檔股票就好
來 聯電
不講了 我不理你們
我要講我的股票
中美晶 對 中美晶怎麼
中美晶怎麼軟掉了 我們看一下
其實我跟你講
中美晶不用擔心
為什麼不用擔心
環球晶沒有陣亡
中美晶就沒有理由陣亡
記得我這句話
環球晶沒有陣亡
中美晶就不會死
甚至還會補漲
我跟你講 中美晶
現在的股票彈不到20%就偷笑
我們看一下187.5對不對
最低多少 150對不對 放大 對
現在是187.5 最低是150.5
這一段 到目前今天這一段對不對
24%有沒有看到 有
現在股票還有沒漲3成的
24%很遜耶
所以它會有補漲題材
知不知道 OK嗎 OK
來 廣達第二季的淨利高達287.9億元
助理今天沒做AI圖
怎麼可以 沒關係
那優於市場共識243億元
廣達第二季的EPS是7.43億元嘛
2382廣達
廣達第二季的EPS是7點多少 43
真的喔 有沒有業外收益
有沒有業外
有網友看到的話幫我回答
因為我現在在這邊
我沒有辦法查資料
不然我查很快
助理給我看一下7.43有沒有含業外
沒有含業外的話
明天廣達會噴出去喔
我們用7.43對不對
算一下喔
7.43假設乘以4嘛
對不對 這麼簡單
一年大概賺30元嘛
沒錯吧 對不對 是
我好像去年錄福利社的時候
我就說今年廣達有機會30元
大家都不相信 我印象中 是啊
那你看29.72喔 是不是
現在股價多少 325
本益比差不多11倍而已耶
11倍不到耶 10倍本益比耶
害我都想要撕紙
不可以撕
投資長上次說要提醒不可以撕
不要撕 環保
環保還是要撕紙
剛好碎紙 沒有啦
7.43元耶
等於第一季EPS才5.5
第二季7.43元耶
夭壽 7.43元 然後這個
325除以多少
我有點想買廣達了
除以多少 剛才是29點多少
有沒有印象 沒有
沒關係 除以
剛才7點多少 43
好 除以7.43
再除以4 一樣的意思
沒關係 數學不知道沒關係
我直接告訴你答案
10.9倍的本益比
我有沒有聽錯
台股快5萬點了
還10.9倍本益比
然後這家股票是家喻戶曉 瘋了喔
不懂他們為什麼不想買老AI
明天先噴再說 好不好 OK
廣達我重新考慮要不要買回它 好不好
哲哲冷靜 好不好
哲哲說要噴一定會噴
明天應該有機會噴啦 好不好 OK
氣到要撕紙
環球晶最香啦 OK
所以台股怎麼會貴
台股好貴 台股本益比很貴
你看哪些股票嘛
台達電很貴啊
廣達會不貴嗎
今天來個股災再跌個2萬點
廣達也不會死多慘啦
你看像我們專業的
你看你們隨便考一個東西
我都臨時讓你們考
你看什麼AI語音客服
我都臨時這樣子 你知道嗎 是
都臨時 都在Live
跳舞也是Live的這樣
搞得像明星一樣 壓力很大
可是你們隨便問我 問不倒我
問跳舞可能會問倒我啦
問這個頭腦
我光股票投資相關的
我就是贏家啦 好不好
看一下這些什麼
一下子賺200%
什麼欣興以前賺100多%
有沒有看到
年初有沒有看到欣興300多
你不要開玩笑
現在欣興800塊就不開心了
有沒有看到 有
我就是都買在低點啦
是不是 聯發科 國巨也是一樣
有沒有看到
這是賣掉的績效有沒有看到
廣達327
327我賣掉
現在還是327
那我明天考慮再買
好不好 OK嗎
再買一次它 OK嗎
所以還不錯吧
我考慮 謝謝大家啦
就是你看 我也是很正面思考
你硬要問我廣達
我覺得這一檔股票不錯
我考慮明天買
我不代表真的買
那會不會買
你不會參加我的會員喔
你不能每天問我啊 各位 是不是
便宜的 免錢的最貴
記得這件事
我從小到大我就不會被人家騙
我看到路邊的
幫你塗一下 幫你怎麼樣
不要
有人要免費對我好 我還不要
我是真的 你記得一件事
有人要免費對我好
你知道那種很容易被人家詐騙都是
都覺得穩了
很輕鬆可以賺錢
免費的
都其實會被騙的人
我不是在攻擊人家
都是覺得免費的不一定不好
再講一次 會被騙的人
錯了 免費的最貴
我從來不相信這種事情
所以我覺得我們會費合理 你知道嗎
好啦 要不要參加隨便你
我不是要跟你推銷
我是怕你被騙
這樣懂不懂 懂
跟大家講
所以你不要
可是你不參加我的會員沒關係
可是你不要叫我免費服務
沒有這回事 不好意思
要免費服務很簡單
你就等一年一次
台灣50什麼時候買進好不好
你就跟著做就好
國巨3根漲停板
來 念一下
8月13號星期四早上9點22分
恭喜2327國巨
開高走高一路急拉
成功鎖上漲停
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺快31%
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
國巨大家都跟上了嗎
國巨大家跟上了沒
所以恭喜2327國巨
國巨開高走高一路急拉
成功鎖上漲停板
賺31% 這是普通會員簡訊
漲停 漲停 漲停
你要買的時候已經買不到
你說你今天敢追漲停
勇者
環球晶也是一樣有沒有看到
今天也漲停了 又漲停了
你們一堆人 有些人在急著抱怨
哲哲怎麼那麼遜 哲哲怎麼只有你賺
你不懂嗎
那時候跌的時候是讓你賺更多
你隨便買環球晶
賺得比我台灣50多
我現在賺1500萬又怎麼樣
你買個環球晶
都賺得比我多了 大家 是不是
恭喜6488環球晶
股價開高走高一路急拉
成功鎖上漲停
我最高已經大賺86%
你有沒有想過一件事情
我一檔股票
我記得好像賺了170%左右
就是環球晶
天啊 我都沒走耶
為什麼1600我沒走
我打算2000以上
3000以上啊 各位
我再講一次
你要懂我什麼託管推論這一塊
每一家公司到最後都需要AI
以前不需要AI
是因為以前的AI像智障一樣
當他知道發現
AI可以取代很多人力的時候
每一家公司都願意花錢找一個人
生出來AI程式 找一家公司
所以這些AI公司就可以變現
就會賺錢 就不會泡沫了
講AI會泡沫是傻瓜
他根本沒在用AI
你們沒在用AI
不要講AI是泡沫 沒有資格
記得我講這句話
所以這些所有的股票
基本上還會再創新高
很幸福 我要幸福
因為你要記得一件事情
趕快存錢起來 什麼意思
這個以後再說 為什麼
以前 我看現在日本人很可憐
20幾年前我還記得
家人的姐姐的朋友
爸爸500萬日元
那時候我覺得很高
那時候500萬日元是台灣的200萬
那時候可能台積電
員工可能不到50萬
沒跟你開玩笑
薪水不到50萬 現在呢
他們現在500萬就偷笑了
可是500萬還不到100萬年薪
對啊 因為才0.19 0.2而已
500萬日元
可是台積電已經變成3 400萬了
十年河東 十年河西
以前就是日本的世界
現在是台灣的世界
趕快趁這時候把錢存起來
賺大一筆
我不知道以後十年會怎麼看
我不知道後面十年怎麼看
可是我知道這五年來台灣會賺翻天
好好把握著
不是一輩子這樣吃香喝辣
哲哲很準
我也不一定一輩子吃香喝辣
可是你要趁我在吃香喝辣的時候
參加我的會員
我看很遠
你以為我喊十萬點是胡扯喊的
我最在乎的是面子
不是那1000萬
5萬點說到就會到
10萬點 我老實跟你講
那是因為我公開講
我不覺得4年才會
我不覺得5年才會達到
我也不覺得4年
有可能3年以內就達到
我沒跟你開玩笑 我再講一次
這麼快嗎
10萬點有可能3年內就達到
有沒有嚇到你 有啊
10萬點有可能3年內達到
從現在開始3年內
只是我不想要
這句話我不想要變成主打曲
主打歌你知道嗎
因為我要保守一點
我怕有萬一 你懂不懂
3年內就有機會10萬點
嚇到你了 3年喔
我不是亂講話
你要記得為什麼
我創造那麼多紀錄
不論是我的
你告訴我 我有什麼特別電視節目
我們以前從電視頻道出來的
我有任何財經頻道捧郭哲榮嗎
好像沒有
沒有耶 根本就沒有
為什麼我還這麼紅
準啊 不然呢
真的當哲哲帥喔
有些人覺得我帥
我不賺錢會帥嗎
我不能讓你賺錢帥嗎
所以你去想想看我的未來好不好
預測未來 記得我這句話
10萬點很快就來了
記得我這句話
AI 每一家公司都需要AI
每一家公司到時候
都會買AI的應用程式
恭喜5483中美晶
股價表現強勢
一度噴到快漲停
手上持股抱好抱牢 好不好
鴻海今天比較弱
廣達明天可能會拉起來
有沒有可能廣達拉起來
一起拉鴻海
也有可能 或者我去買廣達
或者加碼鴻海
這是秘密啊 好不好
這是秘密
自己要不要參加這個專案
自己考慮好不好
這個我不勉強
逆轉188專案
自己來電洽詢0800668085好不好
來 我們最後再給你看一個股票
所以你看中美晶拉回
不用擔心
廣達不錯
廣達最新的財報不錯
然後還有 對
挪威的主權基金都來台灣了
這個沒時間講
你看我做那麼多AI圖
真的很認真 你看
鴻海的訂單能見度
挪威主權基金都來台灣了
所以很多外資是棄韓國
棄韓保台
所以你要把握住
現在幾分
50要結束了
我們看還有什麼股票
5347世界先進 是不是
世界先進很不錯
世界先進缺點是沒有跌很凶
都有機會噴出去
中美晶很甜
到時候 這個就跟6488環球晶一樣
是不是 700元你在忙著抱怨我
結果現在已經1000元了
是不是 是
不要亂抱怨哲哲
就像群聯一樣
一堆人那時候在抱怨 有沒有看到
現在彈成這樣子有沒有看到
國巨你也在抱怨 是不是
我幫了很多人忙
瑤池金母什麼的
希望我能幫到他們
希望他們有覺得我有幫到他們
好不好 沒關係
沒覺得也沒關係
至少國巨就是低檔
是我給你的信心 好不好 OK嗎
記得 你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
好不好
賺了1500萬
什麼時候要走
至少5萬點以上
我打算還是6萬點再走
要賺大概5000萬 好不好
6萬點以上再走 好不好
還有MSCI新增多檔記憶體要噴了
記憶體本來就會噴了
什麼都會缺
好不好
5萬會不會提早達標
8月5萬我沒有信心
我也不希望戲一下演完
可是今年5萬點是沒問題的
我認為是沒問題的
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
我們好多股票很強啊
忘記講這些什麼
微星啊 什麼今天創新高啊
真的沒時間講了好不好
精材還有機會再創新高
真的沒時間講
一堆股票準備再創新高
你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師好不好
今天太多股票漲停了啦 真的啦
6488環球晶
國巨你告訴我誰最懂被動元件
It's me
要不要跳舞
不要跳開玩笑
會跳嗎 不會
不會那算了
改天學一下 沒有啦 開玩笑
好啦 就這樣子啦
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
想清楚 想明白
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
逆轉188專案
來電洽詢或者怎樣
直接私訊我 @s178
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切遇告在面
1億的台灣50
馬上就賺了1500萬了
可是更多是更強的股票
環球晶也好 連續兩天漲停板
國巨好多天漲停板
你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
也預祝各位賺大錢
先從逆轉188專案開始
謝謝各位 Byebye